yet uh
YouTube isn't connecting that's
weird what the
heck what's wrong with the stream oh
there it goes it just took a second okay
we are
live Let's uh
I don't really have any cool gifts for
this so we'll just post
this cool
so one second and I will go over what
we're going to do
So the plan today is to get the first
models actually training on the
environment uh where we left this off
yesterday we had the neuronet uh running
training but not actually doing anything
CU we have to hook up some Action System
stuff and uh we have to do a whole bunch
of optimization and figure out how
exactly everything should be
working so that that's what we're going
to start with
today uh I'm going to spend a little bit
of time at the start here while we just
warm up on all this uh thinking about
this kind of going a little slow waiting
for the coffee to kick
puffer okay so here's our python
binding and we have this action space
defined like this at the
moment what we're going to probably do
is we're going to edit this a little bit
we're going to have to think about
targeting and we're going to have to
change a couple things to match
this
yeah I think we'll keep the uh the
action space at least for the very start
of training we'll keep it discreet we do
have continuous support in puffer lib
now welcome
Constantine hi Joseph really excited
about someone building good info for RL
how many SPS did you manage to get
yesterday we managed to get up to 1.3
million STS per second single thread for
the simulation itself um so you know
that's just one one core uh it was a
little bit lower when you were running
longer games or running multiple
environments at the same time still like
700k will will have a consistent 1
million though I'm pretty confident with
that and then for training training got
as high as 800,000 steps per second on
one
GPU um with uh same model that we use
for like the grid and the snake en
environment essentially it's pretty
small 150k parameters that will also be
1 million steps per second flat by the
time I am done with it it's just going
to take a little bit of working so for
context here because these are all like
just really big numbers that um don't
make much intuitive sense uh 1 million
steps per second is training on five and
a half hours of DOTA
roughly like per
second it's 20,000 times real time it's
a huge huge amount of game data and it's
actually about half of the speed of the
entirety of open
ai5 so you know they had somewhere
between 256 and 1,000 gpus on this and
over 100,000 CPU cores uh we're getting
about half of the speed of that with one
GPU and like two
cores obviously it's not comparable
right they have way a bigger environment
more data um you know much larger model
and all that but still as far as like
mini version for open source goes this
is really high
perf and today we're actually going to
get the models to do something that's
the goal and I don't think it should be
that hard because
like if you just reward the agents for
going to the enemy base and maybe for
like I don't know
XP that's not that hard to learn to do
do right like they'll just go there and
then they'll fight and like yeah maybe
they won't learn any interesting
strategy initially but just to like get
a model that can kind of play the game
to start with that should be relatively
reasonable and uh we have like some
decent metrics that we can plot for that
there I'm kind of just looking at a few
things at the start here to decide how I
want to do stuff while I wake up a
little
bit I've been up since 6 but uh my day
starts with a whole bunch of exercise
that leaves me pretty
burnt
so
coffee so I think that this is going to
be uh we're going to give it a variable
for movement
it's probably easiest to do movement
like this like a nine
maybe just like nine directional
movement and
94 so you can press you can move in any
direction and then you can press qw e or
nothing and then we'll do uh we'll do
like
automatic targeting initially just
because that's going to be uh slight
Network architecture
change just so we can get something on
the
[Music]
and we have to change the space as well
don't
we observation
space uh yes actions
here I don't know why we have self.
actions over here we should probably
like put it down here or
whatever so if we discretize
else
oops we'll put it here it'll
be uh
two and then numpy
int
32 and then when we do
step self. actions
gets added to actions like this no no
cast and I think that's
it now we'll have to go mess with the
network
13 start
three start nine
I think that gives you the action that
you
want so this is now your two action
components
right and then all we have to do is
basically hook this up to the uh the
environment itself and then the network
will give you a number between zero and
nine uh 0 through n so 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
non-inclusive and then it'll give you a
different number that's uh zero through
four
and the first number will represent the
direction that the agent is going to
move in and the second direction will
represent the
uh well the second direction will
represent the button that you're going
to press if you're going to use an
ability or
not actually don't know if 0 through n
like this is the best versus doing
separate but I think we'll do it this
way for now to start I think it'll
probably learn either way
there might be a slight
here
okay um let's go to the Sea environment
to see how we're doing
stuff one of the slightly annoying
things with scyon
is if you make type errors at runtime
you can get really unintuitive
bugs and what but I I should mention
what I mean by that so if you give it a
static type in scon and you pass wrong
data sometimes you can get weird
unintuitive errors usually you get a
good error message but not always if
you've explicitly disabled some
checks so what we're looking for here is
actions
INT and okay it's not going to take into
account these actions whatsoever
yet but I think that this should be
enough to
maybe make it do something we also
probably want to run a slightly smaller
scale configuration of this for local
testing so did I get pull
fine
so this was the config that I was
running on the uh the main machine
we're going to do two environments two
workers and an N batch size of
one which that seems really small
right uh and we'll also do this will go
down to 4,000 and this will go to
64,000 so that seems really small but
then we are going to keep the uh the
number of
environments per core relatively high I
would say so config ocean
uh no puffer lib where is
it I do want a tight test Loop is the
one thing and if I have to wait too long
for it to make the environments that's
not going to be
great
uh so I don't know if I want to make
this thing 400 we'll see I'll do it for
now we'll do 400 copies of
DOTA uh this might be too much for my
local desktop to do quickly we will
see oops but we this is going to be nice
like within the next couple of hours
we're going to have uh actual models
training on this that'll be pretty cool
to
see so demo let's make sure it works
first
MOA hi I just came to know about your
work on mobile RL it's a pretty new
project it's only it's less than two
weeks old great work though could you
kindly share
how how to environment is simulating
different characters from do okay so
it's not one to one with DOTA I say mini
DOTA because if I just say MOA like a
lot of people don't know what a MOA is
more people know DOTA and League uh the
map is pretty much one to one the same
as DOTA I haven't implemented Forest yet
but the obstacle structure is the same
we do have different Heroes there are
five different Heroes uh the current
plan is to just make it a mirror match
5v5 uh and the heroes were designed on
stream with the assistance of chat there
is a support character there's a carry
there's like a clear midlaner with
bursty spells uh there's like an
assassin type character that's meant to
be Rome and then there's like a tank
that would supposed to be off Lane
um yeah they just they have different
abilities and skills we haven't done all
the scaling yet we haven't done all the
balance yet but there will five unique
characters that play differently uh you
can actually play them in the
game bro what are you
coding let's actually just render it let
me see if I can show it I have two
different renders of
this uh it's not exactly Game Dev so it
does involve making a game but involves
making a game that's like a thousand
times faster than you would ever need
any game to run so that we can train AI
on it stupidly fast and we can have ai
play a miniature MOA here let me see if
I have it rendering at the moment M MOBA
mode render uh render mode human or it's
mode
eval does this
work I might have to make a couple small
changes okay let me make a couple small
changes so that we have this running and
then we'll show the demos I'll show one
of the gifts in the meantime just so you
can get an idea but then I'd like to
show the human playable version of it if
if we can uh here this is one of the
recent Gifts of it this is super sped up
and this is just like the highle
overview so like this is a summary you
actually get a like a rendered playable
version of this where you have like a
character asset and stuff um but yeah at
a high level it's looks like DOTA
they're a bunch of playable characters
they're creep waves and it runs at over
a million steps per second which is to
put that into context that's 20,000
times real time or about 5 and a half
hours of gameplay per second of
simulation on one CPU
core this is what we are currently
coding this project is as the title says
like eight days old uh so this is a
relatively new project but
it's it's going pretty well ah I see uh
we just had this little bug this is a
bad a bad
merge there might be a few of
these yep that's another one
else I forgot to uh to pull changes
before I started Dev today so I had to
do this dirty
merge is this machine learning yep it's
reinforcement learning learning
um my background it's in the Stream
title I am a newly minted MIT PhD I've
worked on reinforcement learning for
well over seven years now and this is me
trying to make the whole field of
reinforcement learning run stupidly fast
on like fun and interesting game Ms that
we have not been able to use thus far
except at really really large scale so
the goal here is that basically anybody
that has a desktop is is going to be
able to do some form of reinforcement
learning on M's that are very
interesting and ludicrously fast it is a
combination of uh reinforcement like
reinforcement learning methods and
tricks as well as uh ultra high
performance ultra high performance
simulation
engineering buffer mismatch
got expected float got int oh I forgot
to recompile that's
all whether I'm interested in machine
learning do I need to learn advanced
mathematics and
statistics
so I'm not going to say no you need some
math you need less math than most people
would tell you my statistics background
is basically
non-existent um but that doesn't mean my
math background is non-existent so you
can interpret all of machine learning
either as applied linear algebra albra
or as applied
statistics uh I chose to interpret it as
applied linear algebra which I think is
substantially easier to do because then
you're basically seeing everything as a
series of Matrix and tensor
manipulations
um having some understanding of like
back propop and differential calculus
helps uh yeah but it's I I would say
that my toolkit is like 5% math 15%
experimental science and 80% hard
engineering ing that's my skill set nice
I remembered open ai5 when I saw mini
DOTA that's the inspiration I was 15t
away from that Dev team when they were
making it it was the coolest project I
like it was just the coolest project and
the team was so awesome for that I was
uh interning there working on the first
version of neural MMO at the time uh
yeah that was just such a cool thing to
see
and now we're going to have we're not
going to have like that level of
obviously I can't make something that
fast like I can't make that full project
run 10,000 times faster like they knew
what they were doing they were pretty
good with how they built everything
there but I can make like a full MOBA
that you can play that has 20 minute
games or whatever at least 20 30 minute
games whatever it's going to be I can
make that fast enough to train on uh and
to actually be interesting for research
and to get some pretty cool stuff
happening in
there different base for memory views uh
so what happened here is I was I was in
the middle of deving this feature let me
just pull up one of the other gifts for
you because this might take a second and
you know if you're really just
interested in the high level stuff this
will be like a nice overview uh I post
all this stuff on X if you want to
follow the project it's all also open
source so you can go ahead and check it
out it's in Puffer
give it a star helps me out a lot uh
let's see so we have these ones we also
have uh we did like ridiculously fast
pathf finding if this will run this GIF
is not playing but we do realtime pathf
finding stuff or pre-compute pathf
finding stuff and here you go so this is
like the current lowlevel uh just sort
of low res uh human controllable render
you see that you have a character you
have a map there's no artwork or
anything for the map yet but you have
abilities you can see coold Downs on qw
and E here uh right now this is an
assassin character it just jumped that
was a blink strike it has a blink strike
it has a movement boost and it has an
AOE clear and uh yeah Mana bar health
bar Towers so on and so forth
we're going to see how far I go with
this project thank you yeah we're going
to see how far I go with this project
right the goal is that by the end of
this week so today and tomorrow maybe a
little bit I put in over the weekend we
have some basic models that play this
game um that was kind of the two-e goal
was to get the full thing built and to
play stuff and then I'm going to
obviously spend a few days polishing it
up and making sure that we have you know
reasonable good stat
and then how how much more time I spend
after that on the project is going to
depend on how cool the results we get
out of training and how much people
actually are interested in seeing more
work on this project so you know it
could be that we spend another week or
two on it we'll see um I think it is
good to have this type of SIM around so
we're going to make sure it's at least
like a good research environment uh we
could potentially take it further If
people really like it then you know I
can start doing additional game features
to make it more more complex and
interesting closer to real DOTA we'll
see from there how long did puffer lib
take you to put together was this part
of the PHD work so puffer lib is not
officially part of my PhD it was a side
thing and something that I I really put
time into after I graduated technically
this project started a year and a half
ago uh puffer lib but like it was a
little bit of work while I was out of
MIT over a summer on my own and then
like a little bit on the side here and
there and and then it's really just been
a lot of Dev since uh since I graduated
in the last few months and it's been a
lot of work this is pretty much the only
thing I'm doing at the moment um this is
at least full-time and it's been going
very well it's been going very very well
uh reinforcement learning is already in
a way way way better spot than it was a
few months ago it's so much easier to
get complex M just working quickly but
the thing is there's only so much I can
do with ex existing environments like if
your environment is slow then there's
only so much I can do to make your
environment faster right like I can make
your environment not have additional
overhead but if your m is slow then your
m is slow so now I'm just making a bunch
of fast Ms are you still a researcher at
MIT nope I've graduated I'm now an
independent
researcher um puffer lib is my main
thing right so I guess technically
founder of puffer AI if you want to say
that because it's technically a startup
but but uh for the most part this is
more just like me doing a bunch of
awesome open source work uh on this
trying to make this field not be cursed
because RL is really cursed full-time RL
Exorcist Purge the demons from the
discreet big up the P founder of puff
rayi
it's a little startup technically um
we're not doing I'm not taking funding
for it or anything at the moment uh the
goal is to just like scale a bunch of
this Dev out and then hopefully some
companies will want to use it and we'll
scale it that way just wondering has
someone already thought about how to add
unsupervised environment design ued
procedural content generation to puffer
lib uh I'm familiar with the Jack ones
but they're comers on so I've done lots
of work in that
area um
I wrote this really long ranty post
about Jax and how I don't think Jax is
the way forward and it's pretty much for
the reason that it limits you in what
you can build right you're kind of
limited to this domain specific
language
um versus with the stuff that I'm doing
here you can just write whatever you
want and have it be native c-s speed so
yeah you can like you can do that some
of the other environments I have I have
to do some
PCG that was a really ranty bait post by
the way I write I write way better stuff
than that it's just that like the bait
the ranty bait posts get attention and
my good stuff doesn't so like if you
check the puffer lib site and check the
blog on that there's way more valuable
information there it's just like fewer
people see it what MOBA is this game
it's Loosely based off of DOTA well the
map and the tower spawns and stuff are
actually one to one with DOTA um they're
based off of like an old version of the
DOTA map data I don't know if you can
tell but like this is the obstacle map
of DOTA like if you just cut out all the
trees and look for where they walls this
is exactly where they are the creep
spawn in exactly the same
places um but I'm not one to oneing all
of the mechanics and stuff compared to
Jack how is syon for development I
haven't used syon from a developer
experience perspective scyon is awesome
cython kicks ass um it doesn't run on
the GPU which means that you still have
to get the data from syon onto the GPU
that's what puffer's uh fast
vectorization is for but yeah you can
get stuff that runs at millions of steps
per second it's really
nice read the neural MMO papers Twitter
posting is not normal yeah yeah there's
actually there is a full puffer lib
white paper it's on archive if you want
to read it
um I it's been double rejected and I
resubmit it to it to NPS it's a really
good paper it's not your typical
academic style of paper though yeah you
win some you lose some I'm done
publishing different base for memory
views in and unsigned
int this can just be an INT
then I want to get this thing running so
we can start getting like some training
runs in the background while I'm
chitchatting be
fun you work
now Sig
Vault okay
actually I am a web developer but more
interested in AIML is the reason started
learning math and statistics and
building some LS yeah it's a hard it's a
hard area to work in like it's going to
take uh it's going to take some
experience on stuff for sure but it can
be done lots of people have done it you
know you can move
over the math and statistics is not that
bad like frankly one of the most
valuable things in AI is a strong
understanding and intuition of how
things generally work and then a really
good engineering back background like
I'd say 80% of AI is engineering at this
point like you have to know how the
thing is you have to know the
constraints under which you need to
build stuff like if I didn't know
exactly how everything else worked in RL
like I wouldn't know how to build this
game in a way that it is this fast when
combined with AI right like I could
build this game to be really fast but
then it might not be fast for AI so you
have to take some additional stuff into
account um you don't have as much of
that in the rest of ml
though I don't know I did language
modeling I did uh language modeling
research
like eight or nine years ago at this
point that was before Transformers were
a thing uh so this thing should not
actually be able to Segal at all which
is pretty
awkward I think that I have I think that
I did like this hack yesterday that's
probably the reason for this hold on
CMS right here this is this is
why now do you
work I did this really weird hack he
there we
go now you
work is this slow oh no it's not
slow is that it's simulating 400
environments under the
hood
okay
um let's
say let me see if I can get the human uh
the human rendered version of this
running just so we can make sure that
everything
looks uh looks decent
we'll do oops
two we'll do a little faster than
normal
human I've actually been needing to find
a good web developer to like ask how to
do things in web space I kind of want to
put a lot of these things online I have
no idea how to do webdev and especially
like I don't know I wouldn't want to
reimplement these environments in Java
Script right and like getting this stuff
I don't know if I would do like a
websocket ser and then have to just
reimplement the front end or if these
days if there's actually a decent way to
run python on the front end is
hard going to share your work you're
amazing guy thank you I'm really trying
here to make this field like not be
cursed and make this I think that RL has
a future as like really uh really great
space for new PhD students to do
research in because you don't need a ton
of resources to do it you don't need
tons of compute uh at least least if you
do it right and also is like a cool
space for hobbyists and other people in
AI because you know you can get it to do
all sorts of game M you can get it to
play all sorts of simulators right
there's all sorts of fun stuff that you
can do in RL and that's not my only
motivation I do think RL has a huge
place in the long-term future of AI but
uh you know one of the ways to get there
is to get more people doing it so this
is the
game uh I'm not controlling this at the
moment nor is the neural network this is
just it's using the scripted creep AI at
the moment by the end of today we're
going to have the neuronet playing with
it but yeah you can see that they push
uh they push the bottom
Lane and they've done half the damage to
the tower there you
go so that is the environment in a
nutshell at the
moment uh and now we need to figure out
we need to figure out training and a few
other things so this is where we get a
little heavier into the AI component of
it
um well not quite yet I guess uh there
there's one like specific AI thing here
that that's important to understand
which is that targeting is a hard thing
to
do
um the way that agents select actions
makes it kind of awkward to have to do
targeting because when you're selecting
a Target you're kind of selecting like
something that you can see you're
selecting from like a set of possible
things and that's kind of awkward to do
so we are going to get that to work but
first we're going to solve the slightly
easier problem of getting the AI to
control movement and to control skill
usage and the targeting the targeting
will just be like you'll hit the closest
thing to you or something like
that so let's get that working first and
then see if we can train some basic
neural Nets
here
so if discretize well this code here is
wrong so let's let's fix this
so v y v
x
um can we do something clever here
really we'll just make a function we'll
make a
function oh wait we can't even do this
right because we have to return two
things that's gross
well damn it we'll just have to do it in
lineup here that's
variable we need to decode the uh the
actions from some
integers we'll just do int int
ATN and then we'll do where's the player
logic
int ATN equals discret is zero if is
zero
then tab tab
tab 0 negative 1
0 0 1 1
uh let's see what it gave us so zero is
fine
negative 1 0 0 negative 1 negative 1
negative
uh hello Grace
welcome let's do it like this
maybe 1
0 we'll do 0 0 and then
one this is actually this should be
negative 1 negative 1
Z
zero
one no wait
zero manual decoding actions is
obnoxious I could write Loops but this
will be quick quick
enough um
welcome
1 wait
zero Z and then this is one zero
and then the last one should
be
uh the last one should be one so this
should be negative one
one and then this should
be
there okay so this is just a crappy
quick decode
action uh the agent the way the neural
net works is it's going to just give you
a number between it's going to give you
a number 0 through 8 so this is going to
decode this into
velocity and now we also need to
do uh this is now going to tell us what
button is going to be used
so we'll do
if is one
zero pass if it's one we
do uh use Q is true we should probably
set all these to false right
use yeah and now use Q is going to be
true if it's two there you go Val action
so now we know what skill the agent is
deciding to
use we know where it's trying to move
right
yes so we have the skill usage potential
here we don't even necessarily need to
do anything with that
initially what we want to start with is
uh figuring out the targeting
right yes
AI learning math what kind of math is
needed my math isn't amazing but it
still includes like maybe three courses
in linear
algebra um you need multivariant and
tensor calculus at least differential
calculus uh it's like generally
considered it's not a ton of math but
there's some
math I mean it's really more background
like math is maybe 5% of my toolkit at
the moment I say 5% math 15%
experimental science and uh 80%
engineering
okay so this targeting is bogus this is
not going to help
us
um we need to get so right here this
creep AI
want oh my God ha thanks for the info
yeah
um I mean if it makes like another way
to put this is like AI is probably less
math than mechanical engineering it's
definitely less math than electrical
engineering yeah no it's definitely less
math than both of them
actually obviously they exceptions yes
there are a few theoretical AI people
but like the vast majority is is no it's
not a ton of MTH
okay so right now we're using the creep
AI to Tar for the player we want the
neuron net to control the agent Instead
at least partially
so let's go find just the targeting
right
here this is where we scan for potential
targets
attack so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to take this and I'm going to
put this down here for now and um
here and you're going to see what we're
going to do with this in a
second uh I need to add one more flag up
top the flag I need to add is whether
the agent is going to use a basic
okay this is going to now
be use basic attack as
true uh
and and now we need the targeting
information right so we the logic is a
little bit different from uh from before
U I need to actually split this up part
of it's going to be up top part of it's
going to be down down
below so
don't need creep
AI we're going to tell this thing to
scan this is I believe entity or player
let me see what I called it
player
so player is going to scan s. Vision
range
oops it's going to exclude friendly
targets it's going to include hostile
targets it's going to include creeps
uh is it going to exclude
neutrals no we'll let him fight
neutrals now what this is going to do is
this is going to give you scan targets
here of
PID
um this is going to give you scan
targets of PID
we need to slightly change the logic
here I think I have a fast way of doing
it that's kind of
gross so yeah this is going to get us
the nearest creep and then this is going
to go
below right
actually I think we're just
fine I think this is just this just
works we don't need that actually yeah
so we scan for
targets we check if it's null if
Target not equal
null hello
Kawa hi Kawa I mean uh welcome we've got
we are currently integrating the neuron
Nets with the game uh so that we can
have some agents actually doing stuff
we're going to do some training today
it's going to be
move oh we need to do movement uh up top
or no below so Vel X Vel y
right yeah so we
do
d dest y d x and does this make sense if
we do move to or do we need move
okay modifier okay so this all looks
good
nice which OS you're using uh this is a
I think a buntu based container that is
inside of WSL on my local
desktop is this like a self project or
for a company or
organization yes um this is an
open-source uh personal project for
reinforcement learning that is also
technically under my company which is
puffer AI which for the time being is
mostly just
I'm me making cool open source
give me a shout
out welcome oh but if I try I'm going to
butcher your
name oh wait I'm going to just say sen
yeah welcome Sen
what's wrong with
this H just
but okay that
runs is the demo
run any estimates on what the SPs will
be
uh it's going to be it's a million at
least a million single thread simulation
SPS and the train is currently over
500,000 and it will be a million by the
time I'm done so this is perfect uh you
might just you might say hey these guys
aren't actually doing anything and you'd
be correct but this is actually them
being controlled by a neural
network so the neural net hasn't trained
to do anything but it has been uh this
is a neural network doing
stuff
so currently working on CTR prediction
model training of feed Ford
Network would you say that is a good
choice a good choice for
what and what is a CTR prediction model
oh is the network architecture a good
choice what's the CTR
model click through
right I mean it's where you start it
depends on what your data looks
like Sims it scale excited for training
we're about to train it
is m i don't know what that means is M
saturated
good predictions of clickthrough rate on
Google
engine it depends what it depends what
the input data looks
like bro you work in
Cloud
um I work in reinforcement learning does
this count as a
cloud this is where we're running we're
going to be running experiments we've
got the garage CL
really I only use these two boxes for
personal use at the moment uh these
other ones are all running reinforcement
learning on Pokemon which is a cool
project
oops did I commit everything that we
need puffer lib
environments ocean
what
MOBA DB ex is it
saturated I don't know what you mean by
is it
saturated how much how much uh wat money
do they need per
hour not that
much um
it's
like if you're running up at full
load they're like 10 cents an hour
each
but the way I look at it if you were to
rent these same machines the price of
renting these machines you end up paying
for the machines out right in three
months rental market is nuts way better
to your own
hardware and then I just give spare
capacity to like cool open source
projects scope for front end developers
and 20 point it's nothing is
saturated like if anything like there's
no Talent whatsoever like we're
completely starved for talent nobody
knows what the hell they're doing like
whatsoever so like yeah is if you just
need somebody to build standard stuff
yeah that'll get saturated but like if
you're good there's always a
market let's get this running in the
background if I'm going to be
chitchatting so we're going to just um
move over to the puffer box
it's one of my
servers perfect get
pull why don't you develop a game like
an indie
developer it's Prof
able why not
try I mean I I do I do research right
like I'm doing reinforcement learning
research and stuff
um I'm intentionally not taking jobs at
the moment in order to be doing this um
I don't really want to just be making
entertain like games purely for
entertainment there's uh there's a
scientific purpose here as well
though I do love meet some
games Okay um
demo and uh
mooba mode train
back and actually we should probably
um I just know that we're going to we
need to sacrifice a little SPS at the
moment because I just know that we have
wonk
settings n m is going to be two
two
one 8K and this is this is
fine uh yeah this is potentially fine
and then we need
do 800 m per core is that
right wait is that
right hold
on fairly new to RL but as a DOTA player
do you think in a mobile like
environment agents can learn different
roles to maximize their profits as a
team or something like how a support and
DOTA would not form absolutely if you
look at open ai5 they learned some crazy
stuff in that would you say Minecraft is
a good environment for deep RL nope it's
a terrible environment for deep RL
especially through player V player
combat it's a terrible environment
because it's way too slow to simulate
and a lot of the cool stuff in Minecraft
has no incentive to do it like there's
no incentive to build a house people
just do it because it's a cool thing and
they know you know houses in the real
world
right it is been it's been a very good
environment for a lot of other things
but for like vanilla deep RL it's not
great the mineral project is pretty
awesome though the guy that built that
is uh I think he's also currently
streaming other Dev
stuff instead harass other teams while
carrying Farms yeah you like the DOTA if
you go check out what the open ai5
agents did RL can learn all sorts of
really really impressive strategies you
needed like an 8K MMR stack to have a
chance of beating uh of beating open i5
and that's only after you had a ton of
time to play against it like it deated
all the pros are you a game developer
nope I'm a reinforcement learning
researcher does the bio not show is like
a description on YouTube I thought I
said a
description I'm a newly minted uh MIT
PhD I've been doing reinforcement
learning for like seven years I've been
doing AI research for over
10 did you play a lot of DOTA very very
little DOTA I played like maybe 100
hours of DOTA a few hundred hours of
League I have very little experience
with mobas I played thousands of hours
of MMOs that's why my main project was
neural MMO nope not showing ah well
that's
obnoxious I got to add that to this the
YouTube descriptions
then I didn't want to put it in the
title because that's kind of obnoxious
like watch MIT PhD code stuff it's even
dumber when like I code stuff badly and
it's like hey look at this MIT PhD
failing to solve basic problems
it reinforcement learning is a specific
branch of AI and machine learning where
the agent learns to essentially it
learns to play a game by playing the
game so it starts off knowing absolutely
nothing and then it plays the game for
like 10,000 years and it learns how to
play
it what potential do you see in the
field of biology or medicine for
RL so I don't do applications I think
that longterm RL has a lot of a lot of
potential though and the way to think
about it is reinforcement learning is
what you use whenever you have an
interactive process where you need to
learn by intelligent trial and error
whenever you have something that just
doesn't map onto language or vision and
requires trial and error that's where RL
is
good that means you can make a game
bot well yeah that's one of the things
you can do with it
right I've got
a I'm not using
my I'm not using like what I I have at
the moment though to just be Bing games
rellian C hello just discovered your
work very impressive thank
you surprised this stream has been
picking up so much I've only been doing
this for a couple weeks and we have 12
concurrent at the moment which is
fun let me see what uh one second let me
get some runs going in the background so
we can at least have something training
while I'm chatting
can do we want 400 m let me think I've
got eight really fast cores
so let's say we do 200
environments I'm just guessing here I'm
guessing some parameters for this let's
do eight environments eight cores batch
size four go
NPCs and GTA are AI they're not
reinforcement learning they're very weak
AI know they cannot learn um yeah that's
very primitive
AI what about environment where hold on
it's covered by the puffer fish uh what
about environments where the agent
actions does not impact the environment
but slowly changes the
reward I don't know any of those pretty
much you always when you interact with
an environment you pretty much always
change
it deep reinforcement learning have
scope in the future and how can I start
learning it uh open AI spinning up if
you already know some a uh some machine
learning if not cs231n it's
online real po the real full potential
really just game agents no it's not just
game
agents we use games because they're
really fast simulators so they're very
good for doing research quickly when you
have much slower simulators that are
more difficult to understand it's a lot
harder to make progress on the basic
algorithms fast so it's kind of the same
thing where like we had a bunch of these
toy data sets early in other areas of AI
before they could do anything useful
like much more broadly same thing in RL
you got to remember like all the stuff
with GPT in the last few years that took
like billions and billions of dollars of
cash infusion before you actually got
that level of fast progress that has not
happened in RL but we have the same sort
of level of early
promise buying and selling stuff in the
stock market absolutely changes the
environment is this thing stuck at 11
mil
well that's interesting it looks like
we've got um the environment
hanging so I have to figure out where
that's getting bugged or is it just the
happened like the Min Mist data set and
computer vision yeah exactly
believe me if I thought that RL was just
good for games I wouldn't be doing
mil which course do you mentioned the
best General course in AI that I'm aware
of is uh Stanford
cs231n the lectures are online go get
the ones by uh car pathy or Justin
Johnson those are the two the two
lectures I recommend because they have
lots of different iterations of it I
believe
online I'm pretty sure the m is just
Frozen
Here Yeah so why is the m Frozen um
according to you how much is it
necessary to learn the
math such as po Etc Q learning simple
trpo is
not uh PO is really really
simple you don't need to look at trpo PO
is very
simple like it's literally you're doing
vanilla policy gradients with Advantage
estimation and then you clip you just
apply a clipping term to updates so that
the weights don't grow uh change too
much on any single
update the math is not that hard and
there are other things that are way more
important I posted on Twitter a few
weeks ago I literally found a
discrepancy in the PO paper versus the
implementations that apparently people
have not noticed for the last
decade I'm trying to think what the heck
is on this so you work full-time on this
yeah this is at least
full-time how is the book reinforcement
learning and stochastic optimization for
beginners I have not done I've not used
any textbooks for reinforcement learning
or actually I really haven't used any
textbook books for AI in
general I've mostly gone off of academic
papers and
um a few other sources there were a
couple good courses but for the most
part it's been experience and academic
papers I'm trying to think what the heck
this because I want to get this thing
training in the background while I'm
chatting but there's like something
that's blocking in my head I don't know
why this thing would be stalling I don't
have that many places where it could
possibly be infinite
one so the only place where it can
infant loop is when it's trying to
respawn
stuff I
guess so like if all the spawning
positions are occupied Maybe
newb IO man yeah takes
time I'm trying to think what I should
do to avoid this
Niche this is like such a
niche potential screw
up where do I think it
is I think the most likely is the creep
spawns
this is going to be Jank but what if I
just do
attempts and if it doesn't spawn it in
those 10 then you know too bad
I think that there's another potential
error that you can get out of this
spawned maybe I just increase this
range if 15
15 I like I don't know why else this
should not
be
spawnable what's the spawning issue I
don't even know that there is a spawning
issue for certain I just know that the
program is hanging at some point and I
only have a few places where like the
only places I have infinite Loop
potential is where um I'm spawning like
respawning stuff like if there no valid
spawn
locations dumb question since open
source project how is funding coming
from uh at the moment there isn't it's
just me funding it uh I you know I
bought the cluster and I'm supporting a
few other things but uh you know it's
just because this is open source doesn't
mean that there's not a potential for
Revenue in the future the plan is that
as I'm keep building out these tools as
they get better and better companies are
going to want to start using them uh
they can use them for free fre but if
they want additional features and stuff
they can pay for support contracts and a
few other services around
serially how do you handle RL algorithms
of interacting with game
engines Implement them in the game
engine or using python find a way to
communicate your thesis you mentioned
tensor
slicing yeah you need to get the data
out of the the engine and into your main
training code you don't want to run it
in engine that doesn't make any sense
because you want to run multiple copies
of the engine
anyways okay so it's not hanging it's
seg falting
see I'm going to recompile this with
like all of the the safety features on
which is slower but should maybe give me
a better error message
it's kind of weird as well that we don't
get well I was going to say it's kind of
weird that we don't get seg folds when
we run the
program uh for visualization but this is
a lot of data that's running through it
yeah Segal it's still seg faults okay
that's
weird the thing is we're supposed to
have memory checks on this so they're
only a few places where those are
fundamentally disabled
um I have some
though what books would you recommend
for an intermediate level AI programmer
three years of hobby
development uh I wouldn't really
recommend any books I'd recommend if you
don't have fundamentals I'd recommend
doing some course like just some online
course work just like go through 231n or
or I mean if you have that that's
basically the only intro course you need
and then after that it's
like better like bigger projects more
like more technical projects and um
academic papers those are the best
sources like I can list for you right
the major Innovations over the past 10
years or so in AI in any like specific
area that I've worked in and why they
were important and what the major things
were at least at a high level like
that's an important context to have I
can also like list like a bunch of areas
that ended up being red herrings right
it's good to get a perspective on
everything it gives you a
lot super powerful AI that just sitting
in military
basement ah they don't have
nah they don't have
red herring
so a lot lot of time has been wasted in
a reinforcement learning on exploration
without defining What exploration means
a lot of time has been wasted on
reinforcement learning because of um
really slow simulators that you can't do
proper hyperparameter sweeps on a lot of
time has been wasted
on generalization attempts that have
really poorly defined um versions of
generalization that if you actually look
at they don't hold up and don't make
sense right there are like a whole bunch
of branches of work where like
fundamentally the thing that was trying
to be answered didn't make sense and
that distracted a bunch of people for a
few years and I kind of have a handle on
now which areas that I think are
promising and want to invest time and in
which I just don't bother
with which papers should I try to
implement sentiment classification NLP
if you're doing NLP you should have a
brief understanding of the history of
NLP
like before Transformers it was uh
encode decode
lstms and before that well we get into
more classical stuff um but like if you
want something historical en code decode
lstm is pretty easy basic Transformer
stuff now is pretty nice uh you should
also have like reasonable baselines for
stuff because a lot of practical
problems like bag of words will just
solve have you ever considered just RL
for medium frequency
trading nope not doing
it it's
uh you can potentially make a lot of
money you can also potentially lose a
lot of money and the other guy has more
information than you do so it's it's
often an asymmetric information
game engram model is yeah you should
probably you should probably have engram
as a baseline for whatever you're trying
to
solve NP is one of those areas where a
lot of simple tasks are just solved with
simpler
things
up
so because I want to have these models
training today right
so the one thing I can think of is right
here this entity star scan targets is a
this is a cray so this would not benefit
from bounce checks
do you do scan AOE
anymore we have this right yeah scan
AOE no
trading money isn't free
it's funny trading was like the one
baned Topic in the RL Discord because
it's like you guys are just going to
lose all your
money you guys are just going to lose
all your
[Music]
money 121 right
anything I think I had Separate Checks I
really shouldn't be relying on a
hard-coded loop
limit where do you see the promising
areas in
RL so
I mean it's I'm obviously going to tell
you what I'm working on now right
um the main issue that RL has is that
there is there are just absolutely no
incentives to build good infra tools and
simulations in Academia so nobody did it
so like we have 10 years worth of
garbage infrastructure and like things
that just did not get built so as soon
as you stop caring about being able to
publish papers and start just trying to
fix in RL uh progress happens
incredibly fast which is what's been
happening with puffer so really good
broadly compatible simple reinforcement
learning uh tools and high performance
voriz seg fault high performance
vectorization ultra high performance
simulation high quality hyperparameter
sweeps and then from there there are a
smaller there's a smaller subset of
algorithmic problems to look at but it
almost doesn't even make sense to bother
on that side until we solve all this
other
fting I'm trying to figure out how I can
pin
down where this would possibly be seg
folting I'm not even convinced if it's
in if it's in scan targets or
not is it possible I'm D referencing a
pointer to this
null if if the Target that you just
scanned is not null let me make sure
that you actually have
PID yep you got
PID Target is nearest scan a you're
going to scan for the nearest H right
here
creep this is a player
I don't know if this is the only
bug but that's definitely a
bug especially coming from smaller labs
having access to high performance ands
is such a blessing yeah absolutely and
nobody's bothered to do it like just
straight up nobody's
bothered okay that's not entirely true
like a couple people have bothered and
they were met with absolutely no
recognition for their work and then they
off and went and now they have
jobs working on language models where
like you know they don't have to deal
with this anymore
so yeah like we did this to
ourselves otherwise you can't compete
with resource waste on slow ends yep
exactly sorry if mentioned trading
triggers people it's not that it
triggers people like money isn't bad
it's just that like
you got to realize that a lot of the
times with this stuff like first of all
if you're like a beginner in RL like
you're not going to magically discover
something that these big firms have not
thought of uh and often it doesn't even
matter like the algorithm doesn't even
always matter it's often a matter of the
data like they just straight up have
data that you don't have
so like it doesn't matter what you can
scrape off of the Walmart site
if you know the counterparty has they
know exactly how many people are in
Walmart at any given time because they
like they know how many cars are parked
or something like
money well that fixed our seg fult so
that's pretty cool right
I'm from India a highly professional
skilled person like you can make half a
million in salary per
year but yeah this is fun running a bit
this model yes I'm very well aware I'm
very well aware that like market rate
for my skill set is at least that um
but like this can potentially do better
this can potentially do better than that
right like just because this is open
source and all the code is free doesn't
mean I don't want to make money off of
it I just don't want to make money by
making stuff closed source and you know
private and buy like hamstringing
science
yeah the LM hype is very obnoxious
like you got to realize that a lot of it
isn't even the AI people like a bunch of
grifters have just moved into AI once
there was money from crypto and nfts and
stuff so and then they just spread
a couple of it is also Founders
trying to get funding for stuff to be
fair
so but a lot of it's just random
grifters how many M's am I running here
1,600
environments is that too many
environments wait hold on let's do some
envelope math 1600 environments times 10
agents
times uh 12 let's say the games are
15,000
steps
one9 two 240 million steps per set of
full games that is way too
much I think we need to run
fewer uh fewer of these environments
which is kind of
awkward because of the way our batching
works out
maybe we just do this for now and hope
they get
offset do you believe there are no
technical patterns present in trading
charts which Nar you totally could do it
it's just
like you're not going to you're not
going to do this as a like an RL
beginner like yes technically this is a
thing that I could go and try to do um
it's not as appealing as you would
initially
think why don't you approve of close
Source it's not that I don't approve of
Clos Source it's just that like it
depends on what you're trying to do
right if you make your stuff closed
Source like yeah it makes it easier to
run a company in some ways it makes it
harder in other ways but it definitely
hamstrings like any contribution that
you would have to the science behind all
this
stuff
right so my goal here is I want to make
rein I want to put reinforcement
learning back on the
board back on the board for AI I want to
make it ultra high perf I want to make
it where some of the coolest results you
were seeing in Industry a few years ago
you can now do it home on one GPU with
like four uh three or 4 thousand Total
Lines of code in the entire stack like
we can do that this is going to like
this will
work and
honestly doing stuffff um like doing
stuff closed SCE it just makes like
specific marketing models easier it
doesn't even necessarily make your stuff
more valuable right like how awesome is
is it that whenever anybody asks me
about puffer and like you know what is
the value of this and that I can just
say go read the code go use it it's free
it's online you want extras let's talk
after that
least in the stock thingy how would you
model the RL AG to perceive sequential
seasonality of the
data you can tag stuff with time stamps
lstm's handle sequences Transformers
handle sequences we have architectures
for this that's not the
problem I think we're ready to put our
for our first run on Wan
B this is not running uh training as
fast as I would like but I think it's
good enough to put it on Wan
B for
since we've got a bunch of people
looking at this project welcome to all
the YouTube folks um all the stuff
you're seeing me do here in the
background while I'm chitchatting all of
this environment Dev everything is open
source it's in puffer lib um just puffer
AI GitHub
iio you've got it in puffer AI puffer
lib on GitHub if you'd like to uh help
me out a whole ton just go ahead and
star the repo it really really helps me
out and uh everything that you're seeing
now I just pushed latest updates in this
any config Branch you can literally
download and use everything that you see
here I also post all this stuff on
X um it's purely science and RL and
stuff that's all I post there if you
want to check it out
there let's see if we get any data out
of this uh we're running so many copies
of the environment that it might take a
while to see anything we might also have
to change some reward
metrics sometimes chat the people that
are disappointed about algorithmic
progress in RL wait hold on I missed the
messages re RL research is your theory
of change that having fast simulations
helps us test algorithms more reliably
yes and algorithmic progress follows so
let me tell you the status quo and L
right now is that like researchers will
go run a baseline then they'll spend
three months tuning their specific thing
that they think is going to make it
better and then they write a paper that
they did better because they spent three
months on it like it's it's not that you
run a giant hyper parameter sweep tuning
the Baseline and then tuning the
Baseline on like a bunch of other
environments and then you do your
algorithmic thing and then you run a
full hyper pram sweep exactly the same
and you compare the two you don't get
that level of rigor so most RL papers
are just wrong as a result of that like
most of the fancy algorithm papers just
have not held up like they look really
good and then you throw them on anything
else and they don't
work so yeah this will help with that
did you solve the weird thing yesterday
with L2 Pi error I have no idea what was
wrong with that um I still have not
solve that and we will have to do that I
sometimes chat to people that are
disappointed about algorithmic progress
in RL
I I honestly I don't care about like
algorithmic progress I care about
progress overall so if we're stuck
because our algorithms are bad then I
care but I don't think we're stuck
because we're our algorithms are bad I
think that we're stuck because we're not
able to do good science because our
environments are slow and our infra is
crap already pestered about this but
would you willing to
take a PR for clean dqn implementation I
kind of need it plus
po you know that you can use it depends
what you mean like you know that there
is a clean RL dqn implementation that
you can like swap 10 lines of code and
use with puffer lib right you can do
that puffer lib is not a framework like
it just you can swap our vectorization
in with clean RLS and just have it be
faster and have it work with more
environments if you have specific
additional stuff that you think would be
needed then we could potentially do
something like that but it depends what
you want to do with it
always brings me back to deep R deep RL
at the edge of statistical prep
precipice so I honestly don't even think
random environment seeds are the problem
I think it's way more like
hyperparameter cheating and like you
know you're not like you tune it's I
think it's more hyperparameter cheating
than anything right it's like you have
really really aggressively tuned papers
that are always going to beat the
Baseline because you've essentially put
more compute into training and you're
controlling for the wrong variables like
people will control for samples instead
of wall clock a lot of the time or like
if it's better then they'll control for
wall clock over
samples it's just
like I'm not going to go as far as
academic fraud though I've definitely
seen stuff that's very close to that but
it's just egregiously bad science across
the
board Okay so we've just train this by
the way while I've been chatting we just
trained this thing for 140 million steps
and uh oh look at
that how often is it that literally on
your first training run of something you
get something to
work that never happens in reinforcement
learning right that never happens ever
in reinforcement learning well guess
what it just happened on like a crazy
complicated
thanks for dropping
by this is going to become the new Norm
though like this is how how
straightforward it's going to be for
stuff to
work literally we were just chatting on
this this is the first reward function
that I tried it's just giving you a
little bit of reward for XP and also a
distance reward trying to get closer to
the enemies ancient and they've learned
to go from the spawn to whatever they're
doing now to fight um to fight enemies
and level up and you can see that the
levels are going up over time that's
pretty
cool a little confused what's happening
with the rewards they're pretty
increase this is really cool
though got to see the eval render yeah
we'll do that don't worry
we're chilling and training models
today technically this will save us a
model after a billion steps we can
always grab an earlier checkpoint if we
want
it don't even understand a thing you
have a lot of potential judging
Behavior kind of hardworking I try I
actually I put in way fewer hours now
than I used to but I've kind of
structured the whole rest of my life
around my working hours if that makes
sense so I'm pretty much never just
doing random
um I do like three or four hours of
exercise a
day maybe like three average I try to
keep myself you know nice and sharp I
prioritize getting good
sleep that type of stuff but I'm pretty
much always thinking about this stuff
and uh this is like the whole like this
is pretty much all I do outside of that
it's been going really well I'm very
very proud of the progress with puffer I
mean this is just awesome growth on the
project and this right here this point
is when I started working on it
fulltime this is already my uh my best
known
and uh people have been picking it up on
Twitter as
well after fixing hyper pram tuning with
carbs what are some other things you
want to work on uh I want to release a
nice Suite of ultra high perf simulated
environments I've got this one there's
another one that's not announced yet
I've got the snake one I've got the grid
environments and then there's one other
one by a colleague that I got a chat
with soon to see how that's going
um yeah I think we need a good Suite of
simulated environments we need solid
carbs integration and then after that I
think we do get to start doing a little
bit of algorithmic stuff
potentially we get to start doing a
little algorithmic stuff but we get to
do it way way more controlled than has
been done
previously going to call tonight see you
thanks for dropping
by so this looks like it is actually
learning to I it's learning to play the
game there this is what I was waiting
for the reward didn't quite catch up
before now we've got the reward Spike we
can see it's definitely learning
this to give you an idea of the scope of
training here this is
running I believe 1,600 copies of the
game at the same time uh it's running
these
environments at like well we're training
at 10,000 times real time at the moment
it'll go up from there we're going to
get it to 20,000 but that's still like
it's playing two to three hours worth of
games per second and training on them as
well this entire training stack so the
simulation is like 1500
lines um the puffer lib infrastructure
like the vectorization is another 1,500
lines it's very thin and then the
training is another like thousand lines
on top of that so 4,000 lines of code
total for like ground up reinforcement
learning on on
this it's very very
stuff technically I can log images as
well I could log images here I don't
know how informative they would be
what are the specs of the
PC right
here we've got an article on the cluster
uh it's running on this machine right
here on the left it's got a single RTX
490 it's got a 24 cores it's an I9 this
one's 939 13900 K and 128 gigs of
interesting reward
curve this is not very promising here
but I didn't have to say I didn't say
it's necessarily going to be stable on
the first experiment just that it's
learning something
I wonder if the levels crash after this
reward or if this reward crash just
means that both of the agents are evenly
matched so that they're fighting each
other evenly
now what's the screen time in a
day I mean it depends if you include my
phone or
not it's definitely at least 12 either
way
how much do you
sleep uh I I need more than eight hours
I usually aim for
nine and how often do you take breaks uh
I take like a half day off a
week what do they get rewards for oh
yeah okay there it goes It goes back up
they get rewarded for uh getting closer
to the enemy ancient that's like a debug
reward that I have in for now uh because
it's easy to learn initially and they
also get rewarded for uh killing well
for getting XP I should say they get
rewards based on XP
gained so they've got a combination of
sparse and
dense now the thing that's a little bit
ridiculous here
is and this is a limitation I'd say of
more of AI or Hardware in general
but I have 1,600 environments because
each environment has uh 10 agents and I
need a batch size of 8,000 agents to be
efficient with the hardware so the fact
that I'm running this many agents means
that in order to play a full set of
games on average you have to train for
240 million steps for them to play a
full set of, 1600 games so like at this
point they've and the games are going to
go way longer at the start as well
because like they're not behaving
intelligently so I don't even know how
many games they've played here but
they've probably only played like like
1,600 games here or maybe
3,200 is the mm going to be made
available on GitHub at some point it
already is uh it's currently in this any
config Dev Branch it'll be merged up to
Dev and then main eventually but it's
already public it's right here on puffer
lib go ahead go download it and please
start the repo on the way in it helps me
a whole
bunch is this
game is this a game changing n for r a
game changing n for RL how are you going
to get this to 1 mil SPS so the
simulation is already 1 million steps
per second single thread um yes it is
gamechanging in the sense that you don't
have anything of this complexity that is
also this fast um I it's not the only en
of this type though that I've been
making I have like multiple of these now
that are available this is one of the
more complex ones though uh how am I
going to get training to one M steps per
second I've barely optimized training
whatsoever uh it's almost guaranteed
that I will be able to get this to a
Mill and I have this exact same neural
network training at a mill on other
environments so I know it's
possible what's the motivation for using
any files for config well maybe you can
give me feedback on this so I have yaml
and 10 the new branch has uh the new
branch is using any files uh the reason
that I did this was if you look at 10
here
you have this giant yaml file right that
has like it has like this pseudo
inheritance thing where you can specify
defaults and then you can override the
defaults with like package specific
stuff but there's nothing that actually
will natively do this in yaml for you so
in order to get this to load correctly
we have like the demo file which is 300
lines a third of it is this giant gross
config load block that does a whole
bunch of really weird arar logic that
was just confusing people and making my
users really annoyed so what I did in
this latest branch which I'm hoping
people find simpler because I spent a
lot of time on
it is now I cut a 100 lines off of the
demo I added another 100 back for carbs
but like I cut all the config logic off
basically the whole config load
is the whole config load is right here
it's very short it just grabs out a few
keys from there
has the default any file has like some
parameters and different blocks and then
what you can do is you can without
having to look at all the other
environments worth of any files you can
just say Okay I want the any file for
the MOBA and here your parameter for Moa
so I think it's a lot cleaner uh it
doesn't make you scroll through a gianto
file uh I guess I could have just split
up the Amo files anyways but it's nicely
separated and the main thing is I don't
have a giant gross block of loading
logic to deal with this
format it has way better integration and
it drops some annoying
dependencies I've Rewritten this config
system like four times it's really hard
to make a good config system because you
need it to do a lot of stuff but you
need it to not be a lot of bloat for new
for your new
users how's this
going this is
clean this is very very
so the thing is I can tell you they're
not winning games at level
eight so it's going to be a while for
them to start winning the actual
games and we'll see if that destabilizes
the training at
all
uhoh crashes like that are usually not
good though it could actually mean if
the if the M level goes down that
actually could mean that they started
winning games because if they started
winning games then they get reset to Lev
level zero
right that actually could lead them to
learn to not win the game which would be
really
funny could lead them to learn to just
like idle around at the
end um how are our losses
looking now our losses are all pretty
stable so this actually looks good to me
so if this is yeah this is not a crash
this is just a little
hitch steps per second it spikes to 750
but most to the time it's a little over
here it's going to be 12 more minutes
before this we get a model from
this we also can just think about some
other stuff with this environment in the
meantime so I don't know maybe chat has
some ideas here so I have a lot of
hardcoded crap at the moment in
here and it's like taking up a it's
making this way longer than it should
be so right now we have 1300 uh 1360
lines of code in this game environment
right
and a lot of it is very hardcoded like I
have some of this loading out of files
in init in a kind of a gross way
but then like when let's say when you do
level up for instance
level like level up is handled just like
hardcoded um there like all sorts of
just random variabl scattered around
it's going to make this thing very hard
to balance I haven't even done like
skills upgrading yet so I basically I'm
going to need some way to get all of the
data for the game like all the configur
data for the game I'm going to need a
way to have that separated out because
I'm going to have to balance this more
or less I'm going to have to balance
this such that the game is reasonable to
play otherwise the agents are going to
learn weird degenerate strategies so and
I'd like to be able to do that without
having to be like changing tons of
hardcoded stuff in the file where I can
very easily like change one thing and
forget to change another because it's
like hardcoded in multiple places
um the really lame easy way of doing
this would just be to add the constants
at the top of the file with names and
then reuse them from
there I guess a lot of them aren't
readable out of the DOTA game files
right yeah a lot of these are not
readable out of the DOTA game
files but there's going to be there's
going to be quite a lot of stuff that I
have to load in
like skills in particular right like if
I want to have a level one two and three
value of damage or
something skill upgrading is degenerate
in most mobas anyways there a point
including it I don't necessarily need to
include it I could do fix scaling I
could just give it like 5% additional
damage or 5% additional healing or
whatever it is per level um I haven't
done like attack range upgrades yet
if we're going to do that that might be
necessary uh there's a lot of stuff that
still needs to be tweaked and added in
here yeah there's a lot of stuff that
needs to be tweaked and add I guess that
like these Mana values here bother me
that like they're hardcoded like I have
to hardcode Mana here and hardcode Mana
there I guess this thing could take like
a tier
argument or no it could just be based on
player level
I could just make a little inline
function that
scales is it overhead lamp or table
lamp I strain so
much wait is it overhead lamp or table
lamp I have light
bulbs what was the table color I have
have like a black glass table and I
don't know light bulbs and I have a
window with the blinds
closed I spend I actually spend a lot of
time outside these days because of uh
the running that I do I'm running 50
miles a week these days um but I still
can't go outside in the daylight without
sunglasses or I just start sneezing so
you win some you lose
but yeah screens just no long like
screens do not hurt my eyes
anymore like
whatsoever they've just adapted I don't
know show me the training now
will this is the first ever training
run it's running at around 500,000 steps
per
second not optimized yet we're going to
get a million steps per second and it
appears that the agents are learning to
play the
game a bunch of restrictions and caveats
obviously to make it work but I mean
they're at least they're at the very
least learning to go fight and do stuff
right we're going to need to add
additional logging like for Towers taken
and stuff like that
games
one things of that
nature uh are dire and radiant
balanced yeah dire and radiant are
pretty much the
same I was worried about
that these curves are pretty nicely
aligned
though perfect can you show me a
checkpoint right now the checkpoint is
training this this will dump a
checkpoint at 1 billion steps and then
we're going to load it up and look at it
and see if it does anything
cool um but this so for reference here
this will this this will be training at
1 million steps per second by the time
I'm done with it uh I know that is
possible because I have the same
architecture playing snake and uh the
grid ends at over a million steps per
second train so it's definitely going to
be possible and the environment runs at
1.3 million steps per second Max is what
I've seen a little bit lower multi a
little bit lower when you run multiple
copies for some reason but we'll
definitely be able to
saturate I'd love to see what to just
see what the early version does yeah
it'll dump a checkpoint in a few minutes
here hold on oh how do you like this uh
we got this UI this little nice terminal
UI four minutes left
um we can see stats when it dumps them
though we don't have per we don't have
good enough logging for that at the
moment yeah there it is there's some
stats we can see Hardware utilization we
can see that here we're losing like more
than 25% just Cuda transfers and
miscellaneous crap so I'll have to
optimize
that few other things as
well what are you using it for it curses
uh nope this is I tried curses it sucked
uh this is a combination of a weird
manual thing I'm doing to make the
screen not Flicker and um uh Rich for
the colorization and the
layout obnoxiously not all TI sets not
all character sets will render remotely
so this is supposed to be a puffer fish
but it renders as a question card
instead sad
time oh I did uh will you'll like this
CU I think you uh so you were why I
forget when you were at open Visa the
DOTA project if you caught the tail end
of it but I did the math and if we get
this training at a million steps per
second it will be about half of the
speed of the entire DOTA project so
we've had like a thousand gpus so we'll
be up training at about half of that
speed on one
GPU which which means that we'd actually
be able to reproduce the amount of
training that they did on DOTA on one
GPU if we just left it for a while which
would be pretty cool to get like the
same number of games
played as open
ai5 I mean we know that this is an
environment
where where that type of stuff is is
possible I also assume that there there
couldn't have possibly been a full hyper
parameter sweep on for open i5 and stuff
so like potentially theirs could have
been way more sample efficient than it
actually ended up being we can do that
here because we it's so fast and the
hardware is
though for folks on YouTube will is uh
will was at open AI
previously uh
he's author of the mineral project
awesome project Minecraft plus RL plus
well not just RL other things as well um
yeah and he's also streaming on
X would be sick to do Sim to real modify
the DOTA client such that we could run
it on the real
games that's
hard I honestly think it would be easier
to just like
fully replicate DOTA and make it faster
than it would be to do like a Simo real
Gap close thing like you could probably
just make the full DOTA game run at
maybe not Millions but like you can get
hundreds of thousands of steps per
second on the full DOTA
game with like a few very minor and
inconsequential changes
but I don't want this to be like a
year-long project right I mean I'm not
going to I'll make this a year-long
project if this thing completely blows
up and this is like the best way to push
RL forward but short of that like this
is going to be a cool new environment
for RL that runs super high per but it's
going to be one of several that I
make payoff here though and I found this
with minerals people wanted to interact
with it in the real
game well it depends what you mean
though right
like if you want this to be like a like
player facing thing then yeah if you
want this to just be a really really
good research tool for like
doing like for evaluating reinforcement
learning stuff at very very high perf
high speeds on a complicated domain then
we don't have to go all that far
right like my vision is that we have
maybe five environments we have like two
of this level of
complexity we have maybe two midscale
environments in like one simple
EnV and they all run a million plus
steps per second train and then we run
hyper parameter sweeps over
everything level mean looks super
promising yeah it really
does they're going to crash at some
point when they start start actually
winning the full
games but they're definitely uh they're
definitely
training definitely doing reasonable
stuff the reward curve being this shape
is a little weird but again this is
literally the first run
so um I have a lot of tricks that I can
throw at this
like these one Bill runs are only 40
minutes I can just run a hyper parameter
sweep of one bill ion parameter runs and
I'm sure that the best hyper parameter
set will do way better than this cuz I
can just pick the hyper parameter set
that gets the highest level means for
instance
um yeah there's a lot of stuff we can do
with
this is that it does it finish did it
finish hey it
finished
this model is also currently open source
you can go download
it if it selfplay then the reward curve
may actually not be that bad is that the
total reward
yeah we're about to
render
hopefully I had to add this
I have to add these fixes that we did on
the
server investor for open
AI what
not an investor for open
compile l- o DotA
dot or
MOA
day mode eval
let's do rib first uh dash
dash eval model
path well I don't know we'll see if it
does
anything uh I think it's running 400
environments hold on it's running 400
environments in the background let me
fix that
smart though it's possible it's not
loading them
correctly CU we know that they level
up so they should be doing something way
more than this
maybe but these ones are still
stuck don't they level up automatically
no they only get uh they only get XP for
last
hits in the way that we have it
now okay so these these gray ones are
definitely biased towards uh towards
going through
top I think that we would expect more
than this
though we definitely oh no no no look it
was actually just fighting over here so
it has a hard time getting to Lane but
once it gets to Lane it looks like it's
fighting a lot although look it's
farming the
neutrals so I think that they actually
have learned
um
H they seem to follow targets very
well why is it having so hard of a time
getting to Lane though
uh
oh why is this thing crashing I think
there's a memory leak in the renderer
but not in the um not in the
temp we don't have
a we don't have like a a specific
temperature parameter will it's just
what whatever the distribution has been
learned over the um over the it's just
whatever distribution has been learned I
guess that's like technically zero or
whatever but that's normal for
RL you want them to be able to learn
stochastic policies
noise they definitely learn
something but the thing is based on the
train curves I would expect them to do
better so I'm wondering if there's a way
that we're not actually seeing the
policy as it was learned you
7813 it should be very easy for them to
be learning to go to the
mid they should be getting rewarded
based on
so why aren't
they they're biased towards the
lane
H let me look at some hypers
they did learn something on the very
first
run which is
nice got a mini batch size of 8,000 a
batch size of
128k very high learning rate to be
fair reward curve was going up at stable
plot the mean reward curve Over episodes
we have that well we don't have over
episodes we have
oversteps pretty
we have a lot of things we can do here
we can go check the reward function
this reward is very very
low E minus
4 the magnitude of this is suspiciously
low
actually it should not be that
low let's go take a look that's our
hint what's a reward function
so the reward function gives you um it's
based on distance to the ancient as well
as XP
gained I don't currently have it saved
over episodes I could save it
I meant per episode you get rewards at
various time
steps that gives you distribution of P
getting reward at time
T so you can plot this to
see when in a typical
episode they get
reward to
see if in training they have the same
takes a while to get a reward
problem same as the YouTube guys comment
so the issue will is that the um I don't
even think we're getting complete
episodes at this point because in order
to in order to get uh an episode you
need to play the full
game
we'd have to come up with like some
histogram or something to get that it
shouldn't take long to get a reward
though like I think that the thing that
we should do is we should go double
check the reward
magnitudes and we might need to reformat
the rewards a little bit as well
because um this continuous
reward we have a continuous reward which
is like minus distance from ancient or
whatever if we just gave you like a
small positive reward for going towards
the ancient instead that would be way
easier to learn
that's a common
chips distance to ancient divided by two
uh 2500
here and it's a 128x 128 map
0.1 the fact that no single episode is
finishing makes me think you need random
resets so you don't get catastrophic for
so you're mostly correct about that will
but the thing is the agents also die uh
when they die they respawn
anyways
right yeah you're totally correct that
you do need to vary the game States like
that
um and we could potentially do that it's
going to actually I think it's going to
hurt later in training though if you're
randomly getting partial games um
because like ideally you just want all
the M's to desync right you just want
them to like desync pretty early in
training and then you don't have to do
that but I've done that exact type of
thing on other M's to great
effect another thing that you can do if
you don't want to just reset the whole
game randomly is you can just like
randomly respawn agents with probability
like one in 2,000 you just randomly
respawn
agents I've done that type of a thing
before as
well why is the reward so small if we
have this distance to ancient being this
is it controlling five agents or is each
player a different
agent
um oh wait this
is the reward here doesn't look like
that um is it controlling five agents or
is each player a different
agent it's independently controlling
each of five different AG it is
independently controlling each of five
different Heroes
so yes the heroes are different but the
weights are
shared okay this reward looks reasonable
right minus 0.07 that's what we
expect so why did the reward here that
we have why is this reward so
small that's weird
right is the other side getting a bad
reward
no we're we're printing both of them
here that's weird right that it's uh
that the reward is so
different let me print it as it's coming
out of the environment
maybe it's not getting set for all of
the heroes it's possible we screwed up
some indexing
okay ah reward coming out of the
environment looks correct to me
then may I SL we
know how does the magnitude of reward
gain due to XP look like well it should
be zero at the start because they won't
know how to get to how to get to the
Lane to kill minions right um I can show
you the P
reward I scaled it by uh I divided by a
thousand so the rewards would be
anything from it could be anywhere from
50 XP or like 35 XP I think so that's a
pretty small reward when you divide by a
th000 all the way up to like I think you
can get a reward of like three or four
for an Nexus kill I think something like
that for not Nexus for an ancient kill
majority of the rewards are going to be
though
uh fairly small from
this and then when we do player. reward
it gets reset every
tick it does get reset every tick let me
see if I messed anything up with that so
player. reward equals
zero uh there's a stun timer thing that
could mess something up here
continues we probably should move these
around a little bit right
this I don't think that the stun should
make a
difference like they're not getting
stunned there's no
way player. reward is zero
right dis to anent player. reward
subract rewards of PID
this player.
reward and we'll put it again at the
bottom just to be sure you can change
the reward
during and then we'll we'll just run
this again we'll rebuild it we'll make
sure we still get the same
rewards I'm still like it the rewards
look good coming out of here and they
don't look good in training uh it's
possible I'm doing some bad accumulation
in the
logging that's actually probably the
most likely thing I might just be
reporting the reward
infos sum of rewards over num
agents well there's your
problem you're
doing wait
self. buff. rewards.
correctly self. buff.
rewards looks good to
me some Rewards
them oh
wait um am I passing this correctly
I I have an idea let me
see
buff pointer colon
end no this looks good I thought I was
passing stuff
weird Let's uh let's change this to B 10
environments and see cuz if we like in
the actual one we're simulating more Ms
let me see if I like screwed up the
other Ms or
something so now we're going to make a
we're going to make 10 games and we're
going to
see we're going to see what the average
reward
is
ah there he is while air is your
problem I bet that we're somehow only
handling the rewards from their first
environment so like we have one good
environment for training 400 garbage
ones and somehow we still learn
something that's my
guess though if we want to be fancier
about it this was my
conjecture that's the scaling
ah what did I
say
I poer colon
end num
m interesting stuff I started watching
after seeing your PhD defense
welcome this is uh live
building crazy crazy fast simulations
for reinforcement
learning is William open AI investor or
is he doing same
RL he's a former open AI employee who
also built mineral back in the day and
does a bunch of cool stuff
now I met him many years ago briefly at
CMU when uh I was touring for PhD admits
I
believe uh
he was a year or two
ahead what is wrong with
this like what what's wrong with this
so that's so
stupid I don't even know how this
works that's technically like an out of
bounds
[Music]
error I don't even know how that the
hell this is possible
end oh it's not start it's pointer
duh forgot the
it's still kind of low isn't
it it should be negative .07 not
negative
maybe just to be sure I want to make
sure that the rewards are all
different wait so your first set of 10
which is right
here these look
good and then these ones are like lower
for some
reason these shouldn't be
lower why is the first set higher than
the other
I mean it's it's in like the realm of
possibility but I just don't see any
reason why it would be higher so that's
worth
investigating most goes into finding the
error rather than fixing
it why doesn't anybody come up with the
idea and develop an AI that can help
with it CU it's really
hard and the AI are really dumb
when I'm coding more basic stuff I
basically don't spend any time debugging
like I get stuff right this is a very
very complicated
application just saw your education on
LinkedIn how did you manage to skip
studying Masters and go to
PhD okay so I I'm assuming you're not in
the US I technically have a masters but
I just get it as part of my PhD um in
the US it's very common you go from
undergrad to PhD and the PHD is 5 years
so I think they're shorter in like the
UK and the EU but you need a masters
first that's not how it is in the US in
the US it's actually a red flag usually
if you have a masters first like you
usually you don't get a masters if
you're going to do a PhD and then some
programs will just give you a masters
along the way
so like I technically have a master's
thesis did I even update my LinkedIn I
technically have a master's but like all
I had to do is write like one additional
thesis paper for it like I I it's not
even I didn't even have to write an
extra paper really I just had to like
submit one additional thing
like the way it works at the at least at
the top schools in the US is like the
main so the main thing I guess I could
add it like I don't update my LinkedIn
often um like who uses that right like
the main thing in the US is like the
admission is the main filter if you get
admitted you will finish your PhD if you
do the work
um there's like some course work but
nobody fails it again it's the
admission you need to publish like you
need to publish some number of good
papers and then you need to give like a
good defense that's those are the main
things that you need to
do generally the top places in the US
they do a pretty good job of like
letting you do important research and
trying to stay out of your way as much
as
possible I wish they'd stay more out of
your way but they do a pretty good job
overall like the thinking is if you're
doing a
PhD like the requirement to do a PhD
these days is you literally already have
to be a competent researcher that has a
a past res research track record you
don't do a PhD because you're interested
in doing research you do a PhD CU you've
already done provably good research and
you want to do a lot more even better
research
um so yeah it works a little differently
but in that sense it is actually kind of
harder because uh not doing the Masters
means that you have to have good
research by the time you're done with
undergrad okay so this reward is
actually what it says is coming out of
the environment I just don't believe
that this is
true so
maybe
print
dox thanks for the info yeah it
surprises a lot of people from uh I
guess that's actually the case in most
places outside the US
but okay what is going on
here so we've
got some low number like this is one two
three four five these are
good these all look good to
me maybe this is
correct it just seems weird to me that
the first environment specifically would
have lower rewards
right why would that be the
case am I doing something
so we can always train it
again we can do a shorter train run it
should actually work now
push origin all right let's train um
we're not going to do another billion
step run that takes forever I just want
to see if like the reward curves are way
way better than before they should be
ocean we'll do like 10
and 150 mil or
quick how do you tune hyper parameters
efficiently
well I've posted about this before let
me show
you we have what is called the god
algorithm where is it
carbs this is carbs carbs is known as
the god algorithm because it is
Godly this is what carbs does for
you this is a 250 billion step
hyperparameter tuning run on a different
environment with carbs it just finds
better and better stuff over time it's a
big improvement over basian
optimization and puffer lib has
integration for it so absent this you
use uh random or basian hyper parameter
optimization stuff with really really
fast simulation so you can run lots of
trials with carbs you use this and then
it solves everything
looks two minutes
I'm going to go use the restro from real
quick while this trains and then we're
going to hopefully get some uh some
plots these rewards already look better
though be back in a
what did I miss
here so is it sequential and can it be
integrated into any any training
algorithm uh I think it's technically
sequential I should ask him about
parallelizing it that would be
cool it should be pretty trivially
parallelizable though because it's it it
holds multiple like Optimal candidates
Pito optimal candidates at the same time
so yeah uh you should be able to it's a
pretty new algorithm it was just
recently open well the algorithm isn't
new but it's really hard to implement
and uh it was only recently open sourced
puffer is the first integration of it
that I know of in any Library uh I mean
I pretty much did this like 48 hours
after they after they dropped it so
yeah you guys all ml experts here I the
audience I have is mixed my Twitter
audience is way more technical even than
I'd say my uh average YouTube audience
because my Twitter is just like me
posting technical RL stuff constantly um
um the YouTube is like a mix of RL and
ml people that know me through like the
thesis defense and then the thesis
dispense got really really broadly into
the algorithm so you know a lot of just
other Tech enthusiasts and stuff that
maybe don't have the the deeper
oh that's a way nicer
curve
um well they haven't leveled a bunch but
this is a way nicer curve
yeah William should see this he checks
in periodically with the stuff we're
doing here Will's got some really cool
Tech as well though he has been working
less in uh like this type of RL more in
like language models plus RL lately
software engineer only ever made an ml
perceptron honestly like 80% of my
playbook is engineering yeah there's an
important 15% that's like experimental
science background and maybe another 5%
that's the math background but like 80%
of my playbook is
engineering it's it's like I just I try
to code things that don't make your eyes
blade have you done research into RL
algorithms or primarily just AR I mean
I'm a researcher I've done I've done
lots of things things um I started more
algorithms heavy and the reason I've
done more Dev lately is because
algorithms hit a wall and the thing that
was blocking algorithms like blocking RL
progress was not
algorithms so I have the background to
do more algorithm heavy work but I don't
think that it's as promising these days
I think that the key thing blocking RL
is like infra and H perf Sim and uh
small amounts of algorithmic Dev will be
needed once we have
that well I should put a little bit of
an asteris on that like I've done
methods research I don't have the math I
don't have the math chops at the moment
to do like I couldn't have written trp
or something like that um my work is a
lot more heavily I've done a lot of like
architectures work in the past I've done
that sometimes little math things here
and there not a whole bunch of
yeah or AI is going running
[Music]
for what's the idea of less eye
bleeding flat minimal abstra yeah that
okay so I can tell you're a good
engineer there you go that's that's one
sentence to know you're a good
engineer well done
render so one thing about like
undertrained models is they take their
time doing stuff probably we should do
the uh the other client here I have uh I
got to go take care of one thing real
quick uh I'm going to leave this render
up remind me to unmute my mic when I
come back just give me a second let me
leave this render up for you
yeah be right back let's see if they
actually are going to the center uh or
if they're like they just take
okay I'm
back well it crashed whoops I forgot
that there is a mem leak in the the
render so Greg
guy
well it's weird that they they got like
here but then they didn't get any
further well I know how we can fix the
rewards so I'm going to share a I'm
going to share a cool trick for
reinforcement learning
now look how we have this coded
right distance to
ancient and then you just scale the
distance to the ancient right it's a
continuous reward and people say oh yeah
continuous rewards are great not this
way they're not um this is the naive way
of implementing a continuous reward this
is the bad way of doing it because think
about it you get a certain reward at
this time step if you move one tile over
the reward barely changes right so it's
actually very hard to learn off of a
signal like this very very hard to learn
off of a signal like this so uh what
we're going to do is we're going to
change
this I'm going to put this back down at
the bottom for now and uh I'm going to
reset
I'm going reset this to zero up here
just just in
oops and then we're going to we're going
to give him a very
aggressive
reward uh oops
variables we're going to just find
previous distance and current
distance I'm going to say previous
distance to ancient is nope not
this uh is going to
be well right
here previous distance to
ancient we actually have to compute this
up
top like
I
wish rewards code like this easy
rewards reward is all you need you just
need a good reward
function if you go for the Delta change
in distance is a
reward I'm suspecting it would find a
way to reach the ancient evading danger
such as creeps
uh if it manages to do that that's a
game balance issue because the towers
that are next to the agent the ancient
should just murk
reward plus
equals uh let's
do
distance distance what is it distance
minus previous
distance so
wait no previous distance minus
distance negative signs wait so it
should learn to even reach some level
before tempting that type of yeah
exactly
look we just want to see it learn
something fast initially like if it
learns a dumb strategy of just running
down mid and fighting stuff along the
way I'm happy with that initially right
and then what we'll do is we'll get to
tune this we'll get better observations
we'll tune the reward functions so it
learns like to do better stuff but
initially like you just want to see that
it's very clearly and quickly learning a
learning a basic strategy that's the
best way to work with this cuz then you
know that you don't have like a weird
architecture that's really slow to learn
or really crap hype
parameters um it's very important to
have something like that so let me see
it's we want to
do if distance is
lower wait previous distance is
bigger minus distance we
want previous
distance minus
distance yeah
there so this looks good right
we give preve distance minus distance we
divide oh and uh we don't need to divide
by this much anymore
because you're moving one
unit
different you're moving one unit so at
most so we can give it 0.1
this also gives you way better
conditioning in your
rewards because you no longer have to
worry about really big absolute scales
I gotta say it's pretty cool that people
actually like watching uh this like
really slow paced development
stuff I'll put in one little additional
advertisement here uh if you like all of
this stuff and you want to support my
work if you just star the repo this
stuff is all open source it helps me out
a whole ton it's just puffer AI puffer
lib I'll put it in the
bunch okay um let's
see what happens now if we get
rewards this is really good thanks for
seems like wait I missed some messages
seems similar to the integral term in
PID
control integral term in PID
control not sure what that
is okay good these are well conditioned
rewards now I think right 01 yeah these
are well conditioned
I since I I'm going to explain one other
thing well I'm going to train this and
I'm going to explain what one other
thing about the way that the work I'm
doing functions um since I have a decent
number of people watching this hold on
okay let me get the Run going though so
I can be talking in between these
experiments because we do want to make
sure that we're getting a good pace of
progress on this today we need to have
these models working well by tomorrow
um so let me explain why thing about the
the way that the work I'm doing
functions so uh this is all open source
right uh there's currently no revenue
from this uh I'm currently funding this
the and not just this like this is just
myself but there's also like hardware
and stuff right there's like the puffer
stack this uh this supports uh Pokemon
and a couple other open source projects
as well so uh the goal currently is that
I want to be able to spend the most
amount of time possible on the dev of
this as I can and not have to spend time
on like business marketing
right like I'm a Dev so the goal here is
that if people see puffer lib and they
like it and they start using it and
companies start using it then companies
will essentially just want support
contracts and I won't have to go find
the companies to tell them that this
exists uh the easiest way for that to
happen is for the puffer Li repo to get
stars and for me to just keep growing
the Twitter so that's all the pro I'm
doing that's literally it so you know if
you want to like if you want to help out
and just repost a thing once in a while
or you know just you know tell people
about the repo that helps me out a ton
that's all I ask
let's see if we have anything cool now
from
this look at
that look what a huge difference that
made 35 mil immediately level
two it's weird that the dire ones
haven't gotten any better though it's
possible that I messed that
up the reward going down over time is
weird is puffer lib only useful when you
have when I have complex observation and
action spaces no puffer lib also has
best in class vectorization so it's
going to be the fastest available
multiprocessing and we also have other
tricks to make stuff fast and easy we
also have very nice uh hyper pram sweep
integration and lots of other
goodies what do you think about a puffer
lip fork for game engines or should I
ask is it reasonably doable with its
architecture uh yes you need a way to
get the data from the game engines into
uh the thing is you need a way to get
the data from the game engines to uh to
python in general so that it'll work
with all of your machine learning
Frameworks that's with or without puffer
lib uh once you get the data from the
game engine into python land uh with
like a gymnasium wrapper or a petting
zoo wrapper then game engines are always
going to give you a bunch of complex
structured stuff for the most part
that's where puffer helps you out a
whole bunch in getting that data from
whatever CPU process you sent it to uh
aggregating it across multiple copies of
the environment and then moving onto the
GPU
fast thanks Grace or not Grace I know
it's different account
okay so why is the reward going down
here but the stats are looking
good uh I think that because dire has
zero mean I probably implemented this
wrong
asymmetrically let me see
it's also possible that they just
learned a biased
funny so I'm assuming What's Happening
Here is that they haven't realized that
like they basically haven't realized
that they're on different
teams so they're just all going up into
the right so the dire team hasn't
learned to go to the middle
yet I mean they can't really see this
information very well
um I they should be able to learn that
though based on the current
observations I'm familiar with binding
languages and dealing with interop but
the GPU stuff is beyond me a puffer's
all open source so you can go take a
look at our factorization and see if
you'd be useful but essentially whenever
you're going to do RL even with game
engines like the ideal case is that you
have a really efficient Sim that you're
running many copies of and then you're
collecting that data on multiple cores
so puffer lib has the best and simplest
way to get complex data from multiple
processes onto your GPU fast that's what
we
have hey Joseph I've been curious about
your work since nurs last year I'm
pretty familiar with P torch Etc total
Noob that comes to RL do you have
nice learning resources spinning up from
open AI is a little bit dated and a
little bit too much math but is still
decent um clean RL has some very very
nice simple implementations of stuff I'd
say they're the best out there and then
from there you can pretty much do
whatever with puffer lib because puffer
lib our implementation is just a souped
up version of clean RL with a bunch of
performance uh improvements and stuff
there the dire figured it out finally um
yeah so that's the main that's the main
deal with all of
this maybe spinning up there's also like
just a key selection of papers and stuff
I think you get a lot of mileage out of
just reading like the full open A5 paper
po maybe like dqn like a few of the
classics right but the really The Big
Industry papers are really way they were
really way ahead of their time almost
nobody's read the full uh open AI F open
AI 5 Paper covered of to cover that I've
talked to and there's so much good
information in
there very weird how this reward
function is um the fact that the dire is
starting to learn here though this means
to me that I think this reward is going
to go up so I think what's happening
here is that you get negative points for
moving away from you get negative points
when you move away from the ancient and
they're all just moving up and to the
right so the r is doing really well but
the dire is doing really bad and
eventually what should happen is that
they should learn oh we're on different
teams we should be going to opposite
sides which is I think what's happening
here pretty odd
though pretty
odd I think as well that you have
different let me see I'm pretty sure you
can tell what team you're on from this
because you have agent one
right yeah so in the observations there
is definitely a way to tell that you're
on different
teams they just haven't found it
also why is this so
slow did I like forget to vectorize this
or
something this is like so much slower to
after the m is only 3%
here that's very
weird the Ford pass way up in cost
possibly I'm just running uh maybe I
messed up the batch size or something I
might have committed something I didn't
mean to probably that's
it yeah yeah we're probably running way
too few copies of the
environment this is a very stable
curve this reward is a little awkward
but ders it's weird that this reward has
not started going up when the
dire curve is going
up we're going to have to throw carbs at
this overnight to do some hyper pram
sweeps that's really the goal for today
is to get this in a good enough spot
that we can throw carbs at it
overnight have some cool stuff by
morning but I definitely think that at
the very least today we should have like
policies that run at each other down mid
and that we can like train that in just
a few minutes we should definitely be
able to train some neural nuts to just
run at each other down mid
what do folks think about more um long
form video content by the way like I've
been wanting to do a longer form video
on puffer lib 10 just kind of breaking
down my whole thoughts like I I've
answered some of this on stream but just
like really breaking down my thoughts on
you know where puffer lib fits in with
the field uh what is it that's stopping
RL from making progress like what are
some of the cool things that RL has
shown potential on and like why did it
pit her out from there like I was
thinking of making like a really cool
video around that but you know it would
take
me several days maybe a week's worth of
effort to put all that
together versus just doing more live
content
right like I was thinking maybe after I
finish this MOBA project I take a break
for a week and put that uh that video
together
but I'd like to know if people are
interested in
it there are a few of these that I had
in
mind uh this takes off now now you get
the exponential
here I figured it
out edited video would increase the
visibility yeah yeah that's what I was
thinking but
like the time investment is quite
substantial for something like that so
like if it doesn't get 20K views on
YouTube essentially that is like a
worse like I'm better off just streaming
more Devon Building more stuff
right so it's like I I have to gauge
whether it's going to be something
that's broad enough that people would
let find
interesting yeah it it will be
understandable I've got to it's kind of
hard to make this type of content
because like you want it to be
understandable but you also want it to
have something for the really technical
people right like you want it to be
something that you can have like people
can learn a lot from but like also if
know some of the best RL people at Deep
Mind or open AI or whatever saw this
they would learn stuff from as
well so here you can see actually this
is a phase change this is really cool to
show so this is actually a shift in what
has been learned learned so it learned
it's learning here that the radiant team
should go up and to the right it should
just run down mid but it didn't figure
out that with the dire team hey I'm on a
different team I shouldn't run down mid
towards my own ancient right I should
run towards the other team and then
after a 100 million steps it goes oh I'm
on the other team whoops and it flips
around and goes this way
neural MMOs had a good visual so easy to
promote might need more work on the
edited V yeah it's so hard to do visuals
like why do you think that the logo is a
puffer fish it's because I have no
visual depiction of what any of this is
right it's like a big pile of
infrastructure and simulation Tech so
here have a puffer fish it's memeable at
Ed did videoos tougher than
coding
well I'm not bad at presenting it's just
incredibly boring to
do it's incred incredibly boring to prep
stuff for that
like I'll do it if it's going to make a
difference right but it's got to have a
substantial reach what is going on
here 100
Mil I thought we had more than that yeah
it's 140 mil
up I want to get the weights out of this
there we
go what the hell okay that's weird I
guess it just froze on the
screen if RL didn't take 100 million
steps uh people aren't
tabularasa people are people are not
blank slates right you're learning from
scratch and who cares if it's 100
million steps if I can make 100 million
steps take like 3
that CEO of puffer fish lib I'm going to
sleep it's 4
a.m thanks for stopping by
streaming tomorrow yeah yeah I
uh I've been streaming this daily I've
been pretty much doing this daily around
like noon Pacific on it's not going to
be a consistent everyday thing but I've
been enjoying that this lately so I'm
going to be doing this quite a bit
anytime I have like cool Dev to be
streaming I mean it's just like a fun
way to work on code live
really shouldn't be that hard to get
them to run down mid
weird there's no way they're leveling up
doing
this at
so you know it's still possible here
technically
that we have some
asymmetry between like the first
environment and the rest of the
environments
right let me think about that
what if I got the data from the second
environment instead would it be any
different are training
speed I think you dropped your number of
environments from 200 to one did I
actually forget that that would explain
a lot
okay I didn't drop it to one you're
right though I dropped it to 10
apparently I'm going to retrain this
with I think it was 200 wasn't
it that'll be way
faster so then now600 environment this
should be
fast um
yeah let's I'll run this in the
background while we try to debug though
because we have an existing policy
thanks for the
catch
so dot dot
[Music]
environment okay we've got 10 M's here
on the
desktop which is fine for
now I want to see the reward per
environment that's what I want to see
reward because if it's different for the
different environments then something is
is happening weird right like if the
agents are getting different reward
amounts on different environments then
somehow like the logic is like actions
are not being passed correctly or
something weird
right that's what I'm suspecting is
happening because the training curves
don't match the behavior
I really wish X would add a proper view
counter cuz I can't actually tell how
many people are currently on uh X I can
only see aggregate over the
stream very
obnoxious I can see from twitch and uh
YouTube